[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 81
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are we doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing very well.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
It is Monday afternoon here
in beautiful San Francisco.
I think it's Tuesday
where you are?
MARK MANDEL: I've genuinely
lost track of what day it is.
I am on vacation.
This is how I vacation,
apparently, in Australia
currently, but I couldn't
give up on the podcast.
Had to still be here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That has to be nice,
not even knowing
what day is anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
Even though you're on vacation,
we're still having our podcast.
And today, actually, it's going
to be a very interesting one.
We have Frances Perry.
She's a software engineer that
works with the Cloud Dataflow
team.
And she's going to be here to
explain everything about it.
We interviewed her long
time ago at GCP Next--
not this year, but
the year before--
for a very quick chat.
And she's back to explain
way more in detail
what Cloud Dataflow
and Apache Beam are.
So, very, very
excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's a
super, super, cool interview.
And then after that,
we have a question
of the week talking about
how to securely connect
to Cloud SQL instances.
But when you're dealing with
scalable infrastructure,
and maybe your IP address range
is not particularly stable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
is cool, because I actually
did not know about this.
So probably many of you
will not know about it.
Or maybe it's just a
thing that I did not know
and everybody else
knows, which is fine too.
MARK MANDEL: But that's the
best thing about this podcast.
We learn stuff all the time.
It's fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup, no
matter if you want it or not.
[LAUGHTER]
But before all of this
content, we have, as always,
our cool things of the week.
And we have one which
you added, which
is rewriting moviegolf.com.
What is this?
I actually do not know
what moviegolf.com is.
MARK MANDEL: I hadn't
heard of this either.
I came across this post.
It's on Medium.
It is actually a
really cool article
by this gentleman,
Ross Light, who
has this site,
moviegolf.com, that
is a trivia game that
I think his dad wrote
like eight years ago.
And--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: He decided that
he was going to take basically
what he had previously,
and rebuild it and sort
of re-architect it for
Google Cloud Platform,
and how to do it.
And it's kind of a
really nice step-through
of all the decisions he
made, the trade-offs he made.
Eventually ended up just
running it on a GCE instance
with a couple of Docker
images running Go,
which I thought was really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm actually not
shocked that it
was really running
Go, because as soon as you
said the name-- actually,
Ross Light is the team lead for
Go on the Cloud team at Google.
So it totally
makes sense that he
would do something like this.
It looks like a super
interesting Medium blog post,
so I will definitely read it.
And there's a lot of
really cool things.
Like, he talks about not
only the infrastructure,
but also the code,
and even I think
he mentioned somewhere gRPC?
Or was it just me?
No, that was totally me.
But yeah, basically
the whole idea
is like the six degrees
of Kevin Bacon, which
led to a find how many
degrees of separation
are in between a
person and Kevin Bacon,
taking into account
every step someone
has done a movie
with someone else.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and that's cool.
He goes through.
He's like, OK, do
I use App Engine?
Do I use Container Engine?
Do I use GCE instances?
Why did I choose
which one thing I did?
So, it's a good
trade-off discussion.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yup, very, very cool.
We have a second cool
thing of the week.
And I'm actually very
excited about this one.
So I'm going to-- even though
it's the third one on the list,
I'm going to say on
the second because I'm
very excited about it.
Many of you might
have applications
running on App Engine.
And many of you might
have custom domains,
such as gcppodcast.com,
for instance.
Every single time your
HTTPS, your SSL certificate,
is too old, you
need to change it.
And to do so, you
actually needed
to log in into the console
because there was no API.
Well, that has been fixed.
There is now an API.
And also, that API is
also accessible directly
from the cloud, so
that's super cool.
And I'm looking forward to
people hacking something
to make it, so let's encrypt.
We'll update the HTTPS,
the SSL certificates,
as soon as you need them.
So, very excited about that.
Super cool.
I had been waiting for
this for quite a while.
So, really cool
that we have it now.
We have a link on the show
notes to the announcements.
But basically, that is
the most important thing
you need to know.
There's an API.
Yay.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I know, Francesc,
that's going to make your
life a whole lot easier.
I know when you've been managing
SSL certs on GCP Podcast that
has been driving you crazy.
Cool, so, final thing, which has
to do with gRPC and the newly
hot Istio, we have heard
all the comments and emails
that people have sent us.
We are looking to do a podcast
in the near future on Istio.
Don't worry.
We have heard you.
We definitely want to do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
[CHUCKLES]
MARK MANDEL: But if
you're in the Bay Area,
or specifically Sunnyvale, and
you're interested in coming
down for a community day, there
is going to be one on Monday,
June the 26th,
down in Sunnyvale--
we'll have links
in the show notes--
where there will be
developers for gRPC and Istio.
If you want to go
down, have with them,
talk about what's
going on, and talk
about the open source
and ongoing efforts,
bring your laptop and
show up, and there'll
be cool stuff going on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
That sounds like
a very cool place
to learn about
the new technology
and make cool friends too.
MARK MANDEL: I'm always up
for making cool friends.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
[LAUGHS] Cool, so,
I guess it's time
to go talk to Frances
Perry about data flow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
let's do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am very happy today
to welcome Frances Perry, a
Tech Lead on Cloud Dataflow,
and also PMC at Apache Beam.
Hello, how are you
doing, Frances?
FRANCES PERRY: Doing well.
Thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I am
very excited to have you
because it is actually not
the first time we have you--
the second one, but that
was a long time ago.
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah,
that was over a year ago.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, at GCP Next,
you gave an amazing
talk on Dataflow.
And since then, many
things have changed.
So, we will be talking about all
the new things about Dataflow,
and Apache Beam.
But before that,
why don't you tell
us a little bit about yourself
and what you do at Google?
FRANCES PERRY: OK, so I'm a
Tech Lead on the Cloud Dataflow
project, where I
focus particularly
on the user-facing
surface of the project.
So that's our client-side
SDKs, monitoring UIs, tooling,
documentation, and
basically making
sure that at the Cloud
Dataflow service,
we give users a coherent vision
for how they're executing
their processing pipelines.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, so, at a high
level, what is Dataflow?
What is this thing, and
what does it get used for?
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah,
so Cloud Dataflow
is a fully managed
service that's
fully integrated with Google
Cloud Platform for executing
batch and streaming data
processing pipelines.
So you can think of it
sort of as a successor
to systems like MapReduce.
But it also brings in a lot
of the more recent streaming
technologies.
So it can do both sort of your
traditional batch ETL-style
things, as well as
real-time applications.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
when I think about MapReduce,
I think basically--
so I have big data.
You run a big job.
And then you're done.
Like you run it
during the night,
and hopefully the morning
after, you have the results.
But you're saying
that Dataflow also
allows you to do streaming.
What kind of use
case have you seen?
Like why would I use Dataflow?
FRANCES PERRY: So I
think the thing that
makes Dataflow really unique
is basically two things.
So there's first of all, the
programming model, or the way
you write your programs.
And then there's
also the service,
which is fully no knobs,
and fully managed.
So basically, it tries to do as
much of the tuning and things
as it can for you.
On the programming
model side, this
is really where we're
tying into Apache Beam.
And so, this programming
model that you use for talk--
for describing your
data processing
is really a new way to think
about how to process data
across distributed systems.
So if you go back to
2004, what MapReduce
did when we published
that paper is really
gave us a new set
of abstractions
for thinking about what, until
then, had been a extremely
complex problem about how
to process data in parallel
across multiple machines
and have fault tolerance
and be able to do it
efficiently at scale.
So, we think of basically
the beam model in the way
that you're writing
these programs
as doing that next step,
but now for unifying
both batch processing and your
real-time streaming processing.
MARK MANDEL: So, what exactly
is real-time streaming?
What does that mean?
Like, for a lot of people
who don't necessarily
deal with that.
FRANCES PERRY: So
this could be anything
where you're processing, really,
an infinite amount of data.
So if you think about the way
data is generated these days,
it's really often in
an infinite stream.
So I think one of my
favorite examples to use
is a mobile gaming application.
So let's say that we've just
launched some new mobile gaming
application, and we've got
users all around the world
frantically crushing candy--
doing something to earn
points for their team, right?
And these scores are
coming back to our system.
And we want to go ahead
and analyze what's
the top scoring team right now.
So in a system like that,
once the game launches,
that data just keeps
coming in, right?
In a traditional sort of
batch-style processing,
what you do is chunk
your logs into days.
So here's my logs
from Monday, and now I
can analyze them, right?
Maybe, so, Tuesday
at 1:00 AM, I can
start analyzing Monday's logs
because I have all that data.
So that's sort of doing it
in a batch-style system.
But in a streaming or
a real-time system,
you want to be doing
things as the data arrives.
You want much lower latency.
You want to have a leader
board that you're displaying
of the current top team, right?
And that becomes-- so both low
latency is important there,
and also, because of
distributed systems,
you need the flexibility
to handle data
that comes in out of order.
Because if you think about
how distributed systems work,
you can't guarantee that your
data will come in immediately
on time, right?
People's network
connections get delayed,
phones go offline, and so on.
So you need to be able
to adjust and process
these sort of out-of-order
infinite data sets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so,
we've been mentioning two
sides of the same thing, right?
We've been mentioning on one
side, the programming model,
which is kind of like
MapReduce, but better.
It has new operations,
and whatever.
And then on the other
side is the runtime.
Is that the separation
in-between Dataflow and Apache
Beam?
What are the differences there?
FRANCES PERRY: So originally,
when we started with Dataflow,
when I went in to GA in
2014, they were the same.
We had the Data flow service
and the Dataflow SDK,
which you used to program
against the service.
But more recently, so
about last January--
what would that be?
2016?
We donated those SDK to the
Apache Software Foundation
and helped kickstart
the Apache Beam project.
So now that is exactly true.
Basically, Apache
Beam is this way
of reasoning about
your programs.
And Apache Beam pipelines
can run in multiple places.
One of those places is on the
fully managed Cloud Dataflow
service.
The other options are things
like on Apache Spark, Apache
Flink, and other common
open-source run times.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go back to that.
We said that the
runtime is different.
Like, if you're
running MapReduce,
it's batching, while if
you're running Dataflow,
you get streaming.
But what about the
programming model?
What is the main
difference between those?
Is there also like
map-shuffle-reduce phases?
Or how does that work?
FRANCES PERRY: So I
think there's really
two big differences there
between sort of a MapReduce API
and what Beam gives you.
The first one is that the way
you specify your business logic
is higher level.
When MapReduce came
out, people realized
they could solve basically
any class of problem
in a MapReduce.
If you sort of took your
algorithm, twisted it enough,
distorted it enough,
and shoved it
into that map-shuffle-reduce
shuffle, reduce structure.
So a lot of the newer systems,
including Spark and Flink
and Cloud Dataflow and
Beam, are doing things
where they give you a higher
level graph abstraction
for talking about the
different transformations you
want to do to your data.
And then we ensure
that the system is able
to sort of optimize that down
into a lower-level thing.
So if you think about something
like function composition,
if you want to take a data set,
and you want to go through it,
and you want to
tokenize it to pieces.
And then you want
to take each word,
and you want to
lowercase them, right?
When you writing that in
a MapReduce-style system,
you would do that in a single
map operation, where you take
the line of text, you
tokenize it, you lowercase it,
and output those
lowercased words.
What you're doing
there is you're
being forced to hand-optimize,
or fuse, two unrelated pieces
of logic into one method in
order to get the efficiency out
of the system.
Because you don't want
to go through large data
sets multiple times.
On the other hand, with these
newer styles of systems,
we separate that out and let you
as the user write your business
logic at a higher
level of abstraction.
So you can think about
the logical phases
not as they are most
efficient to execute,
but as they make the most
sense for your algorithm
for expressing what
you're trying to do.
And then you let the system
do those optimizations
to run them efficiently, right?
And this is basically
the same difference
that people have had
with assembly language
and then higher-level
languages coming along later.
You let the system do the boring
nastiness of really getting
every ounce of efficiency
out, and you give somebody
the right set of abstractions
to talk about what
they're trying to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, does that mean
that what you're
doing then-- you're
describing this graph,
like this pipeline,
using the Apache Beam language.
Well, let's call it a language,
like API, or whatever.
FRANCES PERRY: Yep
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
that is Apache Beam.
And then you
generate that graph.
And how you run it is
completely independent.
And that's where you could run
it on Cloud Dataflow, or Spark,
or any other runner.
Is that correct?
FRANCES PERRY: That's
exactly correct.
Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
MARK MANDEL: So, I'm actually
curious about one actual thing
as well, too, about
finding the right spot
for using these tools.
Quite often, when
we talk about people
who have gone to
higher abstractions
or other technologies
other than MapReduce
for doing these sort of big
data, data-set-type stuff.
We talk about BigQuery a
lot for obvious reasons.
So, as a general
rule of thumb, where
do you find that
people are like,
oh, Dataflow is a better fit
for this, whereas BigQuery's
a better fit for this.
Where do you draw that line?
FRANCES PERRY: Well, I think
they do absolutely overlap
in some use cases, but
I think if you've ever
tried to write some really
complex SQL queries,
you will hit up against
the bounds of what
that abstraction is
really suitable for,
at least for mere mortals.
So something like
Beam does give you
a little bit more
flexibility there.
But I think there is a lot
of interest, for example,
in the Beam community,
in writing a SQL
DSL that runs on top of Beam.
So they are quite related.
There's been additional
functionality added to BigQuery
to get better join support.
And there's been a lot of
improvements over the years
that have brought these two
systems closer together.
But really, I think
that there's less
of a cliff when you're
running a Dataflow,
like the types of things you
can do are just more flexible.
You can integrate with much
more different data sources,
the streaming, the real-time
capabilities that are there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, since
you're mentioning data sources,
I think that that's
a interesting thing.
Like, we talked about pipelines.
What do we connect, normally?
Is it--
FRANCES PERRY:
Anything you want.
[CHUCKLING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Anything we want?
MARK MANDEL: Anything.
I'm connecting my
[INAUDIBLE] to Dataflow.
[CHUCKLING]
FRANCES PERRY: Go for it.
Beam is really designed
to be extensible
in many different ways.
And so, one of those
is the input format
that you're writing to.
So, Beam has an API
called the source API
that you can use to teach
Beam about a new data format.
And the reason you need to
sort of teach it explicitly
about the format is that we
want to make it very easy to run
this efficiently in parallel.
So if you think about
a new data format,
you need to be able to
answer questions like, meh,
how big is that data format?
How would you split
it into x pieces?
And then how would you
read a piece, right?
And those are really
what are required
for the different
runners behind Beam
to take that and parallelize an
event across multiple workers--
sort of chunk that data
set up into pieces,
and hand them out to
different workers.
One thing Beam does that's more
advanced than many of the older
APIs out there is adds a notion
of what we call dynamic work
rebalancing.
So, as you're teaching Beam
about a new input format
and you're telling it how you're
reading a chunk of that format,
Beam also asks you to provide
signals about your progress
through that, and then
potentially stop early.
So what that lets the system do
is divide the input set into 10
pieces, farm them
out to 10 workers,
realize that one of the
workers is really, really slow,
and tell that worker, actually
you're only 20% of your way
through your data.
Can you please stop at 40%?
I'm going to steal that last
60% and reassign it to somebody
else who's got idle cycles.
Dynamic work rebalancing
has been a huge thing
for improving
straggler shards, which
is this really common problem
in distributed data processing,
where either because of
slow machines or data
characteristics
or something, you
end up with like a huge number
of parallel machines sitting
idle while one
machine chunks away
on the remainder of the work.
MARK MANDEL: So,
going to assume there
are a bunch of like
connectors for like GCP stuff,
like I'm guessing Pub/Sub--
FRANCES PERRY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Things like that.
Does that mean then you
have to like teach it
how to use Pub/Sub?
Or does that work
out of the box?
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah, thank
you for clarifying that.
We have a lot of
built-in connectors.
Your standard GCP
ones are there--
BigQuery, Pub/Sub, all the
various textual formats which
can, of course, come from GCS.
One of the things
that I'm really
excited about kickstarting
the Apache Beam ecosystem
is really that
open-source environment
is where the diversity
of connectors
is really coming from.
So since we sort of kickstarted
Beam in the last year,
we probably added
15 new connectors.
There's Cassandra
and Kafka and Kinesis
and all sorts of
things coming out
of that, which I think is
really great for helping people
get their data into
the systems that they
need to process it in.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds like there's
a great relationship there
between Apache
Beam and Dataflow.
So on the Dataflow
side, I'll ask,
like what integrations
with other GCP systems--
you just talked about that sort
of stuff, but is there like,
I don't know, logging,
or alerting, or--
FRANCES PERRY: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: What
integrations does
it have with GCP specifically
on Dataflow's side?
FRANCES PERRY: Yep,
so we're trying
to integrate as
tightly as we can
with so many of the
other systems, right?
Because when you come
to GCP as a platform,
what you're really looking
for is for all those systems
to work beautifully together.
What happens when you
actually launch a Dataflow job
is that you write an
Apache Beam pipeline,
and you're running a
program somewhere--
could be locally, on a server
of your own somewhere-- that's
describing the shape
of this data processing
DAG, this graph that
you want to run.
So then you-- what happens
with that-- that gets
serialized into JSON and
sent to the Dataflow service.
And this is the description,
sort of the outline
of the processing.
And some of that
processing will include
serialized bits of user code.
This is the actual things you
want to do for each element,
right?
But from the Dataflow
system's perspective,
it basically has a plan
or a map-- you know,
a plan of the
different processing.
It then spins up a
bunch of GCE workers
who it will actually farm
all that work out to.
So your code that you've written
to process all your elements
is happening on GCE
VMs, but those VMs
are going to be fully managed
and auto-scaled by the Dataflow
service.
So you don't need to worry too
much about how to manage them,
but they're there
if you need them.
As those VMs are processing
each of your elements,
they're logging
into Cloud Logging.
And then we have some
really great integration
with Cloud Logging that
lets you very easily search
your logs right
in the Dataflow UI
and see what different portions
of your pipeline are logging.
We're adding some
additional integration
with different
tools in Stackdriver
to get better monitoring
of how your watermarks are
going, what your errors are,
all these types of things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We've
covered the input.
We've covered the--
while it's running,
how you can see what's going on.
FRANCES PERRY: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
about the output?
Do you store it in a file?
Can you choose?
Or is it more like
you were mentioning,
that there was like SQL
statements that you can run?
FRANCES PERRY: So,
it basically, just
like you can teach a system
about new kinds of input
formats and we have a bunch
of common ones built in,
same thing will
hold for outputs.
So, you know, you can very
easily write to BigQuery GCS,
Pub/Sub--
you know, your standard things.
And also, if you
have something else
you need to do--
you want to call out
to a third-party system or
write a custom file format
or something like that--
you have the flexibility
to teach the system
about additional things
there as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So, does that mean
that, for instance,
if I'm doing streaming, how
often do I write to the output?
FRANCES PERRY: That's going to
be very application-specific.
What we liked about Beam is
that you write your application
logic, sort of the thing you're
doing to your program, once.
And then it's very
easy to customize
that same algorithm for
different latency situations.
So if you think about writing--
go back to our mobile
gaming example.
If you think about
writing a computation that
sums the scores per team,
you write that transformation
just as if it were taking a
big collection, a PCollection,
of team and score events,
and basically summing them up
across unique teams.
Then when you run that, you
can apply it in different ways.
You can window it,
which means you
want that computation applied
over different slices of event
times.
You can say, take that
into your summation
and give me a sum per hour,
or per minute, or per day,
and choose the scope of that.
You can also customize
the triggering,
which is how the relationship
to processing time
comes into play.
So you can say, I want you
to sum it over all time,
but I want to know an update
of what the current score is
every hour.
So I want you to sort of
accumulate over all time,
over the bigger window,
but I want smaller updates.
You can also say, and I want
to know if late data comes in.
Because one of the things you'll
find in a streaming system
is somebody's playing our mobile
game on a transatlantic flight.
They're in airplane mode.
And then they land.
Four or five hours later, they
have to reconnect to a network.
And so you're getting a score
that comes into the system
multiple hours delayed.
And you have to figure
out how to adjust that
into the computations that
you've already been performing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, you said something
that took me back
to the time I wrote a
Cloud Dataflow job--
FRANCES PERRY: [CHUCKLING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --which
is that PCollection.
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I'm
actually a Go developer,
and I know that PCollection is
a very, very Java thing to say.
I know that you
can run Dataflow.
Well, you can program
[INAUDIBLE] Beam pipelines
with Java.
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is there
any other languages,
and what is the plan in there?
FRANCES PERRY: Right,
so I think that one
of the things we're really
excited about with Beam
is that we've designed the
system from the beginning
to really focus on
extensibility and portability
to the point where it's
designed to support
multiple SDKs as the community
is interested in writing them.
Those SDKs really are just
generating that graph, right,
which is itself just a
language-agnostic plan
or representation
of the computation.
It's only the little bits of
user code in that plan that
are a specific language.
So it's actually quite
an extensible format.
And then the different
runners can take that plan
and go ahead and
run it very easily.
And then they just need to
know how to basically call back
into the specific language
on a per-element basis.
So what that enables
is the community
to really grow by adding new
SDKs, and setting them up so
that new SDKs can run across
all the different runners.
So, that's the
vision-- that it's
a fully mix and match of
choose an SDK, choose a runner,
life is good.
Visions are never--
they're always a journey.
[LAUGHS] So where
Beam is at right
now is that we have a Java SDK
that ports across, I think,
four different runners
in the main line branch,
and another runner on
a development branch.
And then we also
have a Python SDK
that's fully merged
on the master branch,
but we don't yet have the
portability story totally
fleshed out for that.
So the Python SDK right
now can run locally
for development and
testing, and it can run
on the Cloud Dataflow service.
And the community's
actively working
towards getting that running
across the other runners
as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, what does
a pipeline look like when you've
described it in a language?
Meaning, is there like some
JSON way of communicating that
to the runtime?
Is it like XML, or what?
FRANCES PERRY: Beam will have
a language-agnostic format
that it can use to
do that interchange.
For the users, we
won't have them
interact with that directly.
They're taking a
conceptual abstraction,
which is what Beam
model really is, right?
This idea of PCollections, and
parallel dos, group by keys,
windowing, triggering--
we haven't even
gone through all of these yet.
And materializing it
in different languages
for specific user communities
is a challenging problem,
because you want to make sure
that the abstractions feel
native, right?
When in Python, do as
the Pythonians do--
Something like that.
You don't want it to feel like
it's a Java abstraction forced
into a different format.
So, that takes sort
of a subtle touch
to both make the abstractions
clear as to what they are,
and also feel native to the
different language communities.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So, we talked a bit--
we've talked about some
of the technical stuff.
And like, we've
talked about Dataflow.
We've talked about Beam.
I'm curious.
If Beam is running inside
the Apache Foundation,
how is the organization
structured there?
I'm guessing we're still
heavily involved there, like--
FRANCES PERRY: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: What's that
open-source community look
like?
FRANCES PERRY: So,
Google have the bulk
of the code for the
original Dataflow Java SDK.
And we had a couple of other
partners we were working with--
Cloudera and data
Artisans, and Talon--
who are writing
runners and other sort
of things that could
integrate with this SDK.
And so together, the group of
us basically proposed the Apache
Beam project to the
Apache Software Foundation
and donated this sort
of initial codebase.
And since then,
we've really grown
into a full-fledged community.
When you're working with the
Apache Software Foundation,
it's very reach an
open community driven
by individuals.
So it's not specific
corporations doing things,
but you're really acting
on behalf of the project.
So I think one of the
things we're proudest of
is how we were able to take
something that was originally
basically a proprietary,
single-company thing,
and start to transition
it into an open ecosystem,
with a whole bunch of diverse
perspectives, new people coming
in, being welcomed
into the community.
That's been quite the
journey for the last year
for many of us.
MARK MANDEL: OK, and I'll ask
you because I'm quite curious.
What's the most interesting
or crazy or imaginative
thing that you've seen
somebody do with Dataflow?
FRANCES PERRY:
You know, I always
have trouble answering
this question
because it's such a
general framework that you
can do basically anything.
I think, for me, the thing
that is the most compelling
is really the mobile
gaming application,
because what I really like about
that is it brings home pretty
easily, I think, the
complexities of working
in these real-time
distributed systems.
If you go and look on
the Cloud Dataflow site,
we have a mobile
gaming walkthrough,
which what we do
there is show you
how you build a simple batch
pipeline to do your summations
of team scores or something.
And then you start
adjusting until by the end,
you've got a really complex
streaming pipeline that's
working over real-time data,
ruling out spam robots.
What we've built is
something that can really
give you a gentle ramp
to learning and adding
these new technologies.
And that gives you
so much flexibility
for how you, as a developer,
adjust your programs
as things move along--
as your needs change.
Because they will, right?
People have been doing
batch for a very long time.
People know that
they should probably
be doing stream processing,
but it's kind of hard.
It's kind of complex.
So what we really
want to do is let
you sort of pick and
choose, and as your needs
change, be able to very flexibly
shift your style of processing.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So, we're running out
of time a little bit,
but has there been
anything that we haven't
had a chance to mention, or
you want to make sure you plug,
or make sure the
listeners hear about?
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah, I think I--
since I'm on the
SDK side of things,
I haven't talked too much
about the Dataflow service
and it's no-knobs
approach to things.
So I think one of the
things that people realize
is maintaining and tuning your
own cluster can [INAUDIBLE] not
only is it a pain to
manage those things,
you also end up
needing to change
that tuning as your data sizes
change or your processing
changes, right?
So one of the things that's
really exciting about Dataflow
is that it's fully
autotuning, so it
will choose the
number of workers
that your application--
your pipeline needs to run,
and it can change
that over time, right?
And that's either because
you've got a streaming pipeline,
and you had a huge spike
in user traffic, right?
And all of a sudden,
you're going to need
to drastically scale up, right?
Or you're processing a
large number of logs,
and you drastically filter it
down into just a small data set
and then expand that out again.
So even though your pipeline
might run for 12 hours,
there might be a period
there in the middle
where there's very
little processing to do.
You want to be able to take--
throw a lot of machines
out at the beginning,
scale them down while
they're idle because there's
no additional data to process,
and then scale them back up
as you need to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That sounds
like a great experience
for developers.
So, one last question.
For people that want to learn
more about Dataflow, Apache
Beam, what's the link?
FRANCES PERRY: Yeah,
so I would start
on cloud.google.com/dataflow.
That's got all your basics about
the Cloud Dataflow project.
For Beam, you'd go
to beam.apache.org.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
Well, thank you so much
for taking the time
today to talk to us and
explain a little bit more
about what Cloud Dataflow
and Apache Beam are.
Thank you.
FRANCES PERRY: Excellent.
Thanks, guys.
MARK MANDEL: So, thanks again
to Frances for joining us today
to tell us all about Dataflow.
Really great conversation,
and really interesting,
especially because I don't
play as much with the big data
space, so I really enjoy
hearing about what capabilities
we have in this area for
big data and analytics,
and especially streaming data.
So, much thanks to you,
Frances, for joining us today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
definitely, definitely
interesting conversation.
I learned a lot.
And I'm still not sure if
I'm going to be using--
[INAUDIBLE],, if
I use Dataflow, I
don't know if I will
write Java or Python
or just wait until
there's a Go SDK for that.
MARK MANDEL: [CHUCKLING] You
know you want to write Python.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Have to wait.
MARK MANDEL: You
want to write Java.
I know you do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, or JavaScript.
Anyway, [LAUGHS] it's time
for our question of the week,
comes from one of our
listeners, Chirag Nayyar.
And he's asking about--
OK, so I'm trying to set up
my web application with Cloud
SQL, which is a great idea.
If you need to run
a SQL database,
Cloud SQL is a great
place to do so.
He's saying that the app is
running on GCE, Google Compute
Engine, and he wants
to implement autoscaler
and managed instance groups.
Now, the problem
is that when you
want to set up a
connection with Cloud SQL,
one of the ways of doing
this is to whitelist
the IP of the instance
that will connect to it.
Now, if you have a
managed instance group,
you do not know necessarily
how many instances
you're going to have.
So, how do you do this?
And I came up with a solution.
And I'm going to say it
first, but then we're
going to talk about the actual
good solution that you gave.
And my solution was,
well, if there's
any way you can know
what is the range of IPs
that your instances
will have, then
it should be quite easy
to just simply whitelist
the range of IPs
that you might have.
But now, the
problem is that what
if that range is limitless?
Like, you don't really
know how many instances
you're going to have.
You may have two and maybe
12, but at some point,
maybe you'll have in the 20.
And then those eight
that you didn't count on,
well, they will not
be able to connect.
So, But is not really a
very scalable solution.
So, you came up with a
very, very good solution.
So, why don't you
go and explain?
MARK MANDEL: I didn't
personally come up with this.
Engineers at Google did.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You came up
with the name of the solution,
I guess.
[CHUCKLES]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so,
there is this really--
I think, it's a neat sort of
thing called the Cloud SQL
proxy.
It works both for
MySQL and Postgres.
Basically, it is an agent that
you can run on your machine.
So either, in this
instance, we're
talking about Compute
Engine, but you
could run on Container
Engine, Docker instances, even
locally on your client as well.
So, it's an agent you install.
You provide it
some credentials--
so basically, service
keys, much like you
would do with just
about anything else.
And you can do that through
local environments or files,
all sorts of different stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I'm
pretty sure it also even works
with default credentials,
so if you're running on GCE,
it just automatically works.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so there's
lots of nice ways of doing it.
And then, so you run
this agent locally,
and its job is to
securely, over SSL, proxy
the local connection,
you have for, say, MySQL,
from the local
machine or that agent
specifically, over to
the Cloud SQL instance.
So this means then if
you're running this proxy
and it has the right credentials
set up, and everything's great,
and you're running it locally,
you don't need to do IP ranges.
You just connect to
your Cloud SQL proxy,
and it handles that whole
security thing for you.
It's actually pretty
easy to set up.
It's just a little agent
you can set up and run
if you want to run it.
There are also a
series of walkthroughs
that are available in the
documentation that show you
how to do it from
Compute Engine,
from Container Engine, local
client, that kind of stuff,
too.
So, it's pretty great.
And most of all, it's
also open source.
You can go and have a
look at how it all works.
It's on GitHub, and you
can check it out too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Cool.
So I hope that answers the
question of Chirag Nayyar.
He also mentions,
hey, you still don't
have an episode on Cloud SQL,
which gave us an idea of,
maybe we should do an
episode on Cloud SQL.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, always
love the suggestions
from the community.
It gives us ideas for content.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Francesc, thanks
again for joining me
for yet another episode.
Have you been up to
anything interesting?
I think I saw a new
"JustForFunc" episode just
came out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, I
finally released it just
eight days late because, you
know, Australia and things.
But Australia--
sorry, Argentina.
You're in Australia.
I was in Argentina--
different country.
But yeah, it came out.
It's about cgo-- so, how do
call C libraries from Go.
It is pretty cool,
even though I made it,
but I actually learned
a lot by doing it.
So, if you've ever wondered
how to do it, go watch it.
Also, I'm actually getting ready
for going to New York very soon
on the 26th.
At the same time,
at that Eastern
meetup that we mentioned
in Mountain View,
I will actually be
in New York for QCon.
Well, we will be running Go
Tooling in Action workshop,
so pretty excited about that.
What about you?
Are you ever coming
back to the Bay Area?
MARK MANDEL: I am coming back.
My house is there,
and so is my dog.
And I need to come
home for my dog.
[LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good.
[CHUCKLING]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so I--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So,
it's not about me.
It's about the dog now.
MARK MANDEL: It's about the dog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, cool.
MARK MANDEL: I have priorities.
[CHUCKLING]
I am coming back, yes, so I'll
be back in a little while.
Where am I going to be?
I don't know where I'm going to
be for the next little while.
I'm spending some
time in San Francisco
working on some projects.
I have a secret
project in the works
that I haven't
told anyone about,
but I expect I'll also have some
blog posts out more about game
servers and Kubernetes coming
out in the next few weeks
as well.
So I'm taking a
little travel respite,
and we'll see what happens.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Francesc, thanks
again for joining me.
I know I said that
before, but I really
appreciate you taking the time.
I love doing these episodes
with you, so thanks again
for yet another week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you, Mark
for taking time out of your,
I'm sure, incredibly
busy, crowded vacations,
but well-deserved vacations.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And thank
you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]